what was the original itis when you went
out to actually start the first company
yeah what were you doing was kind of the
thought process behind you you always
wanted to do it but like what was the
actual genesis of it you know what I was
sick of creating value for others that I
wasn't participating in myself that's
the like Cliff Notes version but I had
gotten to a place in my career where I
was you know going in and helping
organizing companies either for IPO or
you know we were sort of packaging it
for sale so I really kind of had gotten
a lesson and what does it take to put
together a company the right way and
then how am I not doing this for myself
and I had enough years that there was
enough of a track record of credibility
that you know it was still ballsy as
hell I mean look at me I don't fit the
part to invest him for a pharmaceutical
CEO but I thought the hell with that I
can go find some science and I can take
you to people like me who exist in these
environments they're you know high
achievers but they're totally uninspired
like this is an industry that I love for
what it does I don't love how they get
it done and so I'm thinking alright
that's my hypothesis like can I get
these people put them together well you
know what I taught it's late clean slate
doing it on my own terms like I really
call it that for that reason click these
people together we got an asset that was
the only long-acting testosterone FDA
approved only long-acting testosterone
for men and in four years we've built it
to the second most prescribed among
neurologists and it was really that DNA
yeah how does that work so I think a lot
of people don't understand the
pharmaceutical industry and kind of the
connection between there's science that
goes on actually developing the drugs
getting them approved and then there's a
whole other part of the business of you
gotta get the word you actually have to
explain to doctors and those prescribing
why this has value why it's different
all that maybe talk a little bit about
those two parts of the business well you
know it is like the great mystery isn't
it like health care in general and I
will say like I'm in an industry that I
used to say we were one wrong
the latter from tobacco companies not
like same level I mean let's be honest
for people who are watching like they
hate Pharma that's their perception from
the media but you know what we hate in
the light of day we depend on in the
dark of night if our children are sick
we depend on in this moment I actually
think this moment is an extraordinary
moment for appreciation of innovation so
you know from a pharma company
perspective there is one this
extraordinarily long process of research
and development to get a product to
approval we will lose billions of
dollars on a bet that something will
work that is a rigorous process all
regulated blah blah blah once you've got
that approval you now have to educate
the market we all know like you can't
turn on the TV and not see a drug ad but
you know most of that behind the scenes
is really going in and educating a
clinician base and my first company
slate actually had an asset that was FDA
approved already it hadn't been really
marketed and so my mission wasn't
actually to educate the marketing get
the word out on so I built an
organization that was dominantly you
know infield folks that called on
doctors around the country urologist
specifically